hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer runde in
die kommentare geschrieben
genau das was die gefahren haben
ich hab das spiel noch einmal gespielt
wir klicken einfach mal auf play und
stürzen uns in das studium eines der
sieg auf jeden fall sehr happy aus
ach so das ist ich habe das noch nie
gespielt mir nicht mal angeguckt ich
sechs prozent ist doch schon mal eine
leistung freuen und da kam mir
eigentlich schon mal froh drauf sein
kommen
okay das geht einfach noch weiter ich
dachte ich jetzt geschafft
diese muss was geht immer wieder los ich
dachte ich könnte mich mal ganz kurz
ausruhen mal kommentar sagen aber es
geht wieder los im roxy einfach über
diese dreiecke die ich hab mal wieso
sind da eigentlich überall dreiecke
haben bruder das sei nicht so schwer ich
muss man einfach mal vorstellen dass ich
der beste bin und jetzt eben drüber
ich muss das einfach zu 100% einmal
komplett hintereinander alles an einem
stück ohne unterbrechungen schaffen dass
das geht doch gar nicht das ist sowas
natürlich konkreter dann sagt man
einfach wieder dass man als komma und
schafft das eben gern wie verdammt ins
training kg ist denn da man denkt man
kann mir einfach noch mal hoch hüpfen
legt die soja gaben das gehört zum
ablauf
in den bünden bündeln mündende linden
windes verstand ich glaube es gibt so
ganz ganz viele verschiedene level und
dieses level da stand zum beispiel
gerade am anfang stand die tempton also
mein zehnter versucht dieses level hier
zu schaffen und ich muss es quasi in
einem land schaffen die sich beim
nächsten level bindet macht den fehler
nicht ich mache den fehler nicht sagt
jetzt bin ich hier und weil er geht so
weiter geht's die farbe fertig und was
ist dass ich glaub ich geh ja ich bin
offen richtig guten weg das richtig gut
abzuschließen glaubwürdig jetzt finde
ich bin ein quadrat da war günstig auf
die mütze verpasst mach dir keine
hoffnungen quadrat als ob ich die ganze
scheiße die da von vorne machen muss ja
mir egal kleines quadrat du kannst ruhig
weiter die ganze zeit gegen schwimmen
view bestes wasser bekomme ich fünf
millionen euro für das ich das zeige es
bestimmt ein richtig spannendes video
gott oder kommen beim ein 30 mal so
scharf wie es jetzt ein ende ist immer
wieder neu anfangen freunde dass er ich
verstehe es nicht wie qsc was kann man
an diesem spiel cool finden wieso
schreibt mir dass jeder in die
kommentare dass das spielen soll ich mag
eigentlich spiele wo die grafik so
simpel ist aber es ist einfach das ist
dazu das ist doch nur ob die entwickler
wollen doch quasi dass man sich aufregt
okay ich bin mein portal jetzt geht es
wieder ab hier vor allem die musik
rassen dann auch mal so richtig aus
[Musik]
komm bruder und jetzt werden wir das
quadrat münster verpasst es kann doch
nicht sein dass ich immer wieder von
vorne starten muss ein retriever so dass
ich mir wenigstens mit coins noch einen
checkpoint kaufen konnte und das würde
ich hier direkt machen wenn ich wieder
das quadrat nun aber nein die entwickler
von geometrie des nicht geldgeil okay
jetzt kommt wieder meinen haspa hat
wieso kann ich mir da nicht diese ach
nein das ist das letzte mal dass ich
versuche dieses level hier zu schaffen
das kann echt nicht
jetzt packt die chance sich bei den
kröten letzter versuch von letzter
gottverdammte versuch das ist eine
ganztägige kacke
das ist jetzt hier wir machen jetzt mal
und dann gehen wir mal in back on track
ich hoffe dass das empfinden ding
guck mal das teil springt für uns guck
mal buch ganz toll super gemacht spielt
das spiel ist ein richtiges spiel das
ist etwas richtiges verkomme wenn der so
eine scheiße spiel jetzt muss ich hier
ich dachte die dinge wollen wir helfen
und die wollen mich einfach trotzdem
umbringen ich kann so was nicht lange
spielen er mit platzen da ich gehirn
adern gehen dann auch ich habe dafür
echt keine konzentration mehr leute es
ist einfach 7 uhr am abend wie gehen
gleich d booker gucken ihm vor noch
schön burger essen und ich bin hier
einfach wieder und spielt wieder schwer
leute wollen sich trainer spieler aber
das ist das ding schubst mich da so hoch
ich kann gar nicht weiter springen wenn
in jedem gott verdammte scheiße jetzt
irgendeinen feature zugefügt werden also
dieses spiel ist ja nicht ganz billig
und das erinnere mich so ein bisschen
das ist so ein bisschen wie dieses make
them
was ich auch schon mal gespielt hat und
da haben das auch die meisten
geschrieben und dann kaufe ich mir diese
app für 1 eur 79 und das einzige was
passiert ist dass mich aufregen jetzt
den sprung kommt hier so wir gehen in
ein anderes level coming soon hexe mein
gott die sie gar nicht begeistert
wie soll ich da denn rüberspringen oh
mein gott oh mein gott oh mein gott wie
der hey ich bin hier drauf jeder hier
zack zack hier drauf hier drauf hier
darauf jedoch jeder so hier hoch ich
verstehe die scheiße nicht die wahrheit
damit dieses spiel nicht mal sagen was
das hier denn alles das ist doch ich
meine wer von euch ist eigentlich immer
noch dran das ist irgendwie bisschen
dumm wenn ihr das seht seit der
automatischen schreibt mal dran in die
kommentare wenn ihr dran sein
kann ich mich viel eventuell daran
festhalten und nicht probiert jetzt
nochmal geht denn da wahrscheinlich alle
eingefleischten dingsda mit rita spieler
jetzt wieder luca bitte stirb einfach
wir gehen jetzt wieder als ganz erste
level und das packen br ziehen wenn man
das so schön back to the roots mit conny
wenn wir dieses spiel eins gezeigt hat
dann dass die illuminaten sind ich habe
glaube ich noch nie so viele dreieck in
einem spiel gesetzt habe ich auch schon
oft gesagt manchmal man im gefühl wenn
man neuen highscore und ich sag ja auch
oft wenn ich einen neuen highscore
machen möchte dann kündige ich das ja
auch an und ich glaube dass ich jetzt
sogar recht auf dem guten weg bin 9
heißt großen ballon jetzt zurück jetzt
sind wir nämlich ein quadrat und jetzt
wird dem fahrrad freunde
[Musik]
freunde einen daumen hoch befreit mich
aus dieser welt einen daumen hoch gleich
ein respekt ein daumen hoch gleich ein
mitleid diese ganze scheiß facebook
daumen hoch kacke ist es denn wahr da
fliege ich gegen so einen pfeiler ich
würde sagen das war's mit dem video wenn
wir dieses spiel eines gezeigt hat dann
dass ich unscharfen dann dass ich
vergessen meine brille aufzusetzen hat
sich in der zeit sehr oft vergessen habe
aber ich habe einfach keinen bock mehr
auf diese brille und ich denke meine
augen halten sich aber das kann nicht
sein kommen das einzige was ich wirklich
machen seht ihr gerade ich fahre gegen
einen dreieck und ich bekomme einfach
ein und schied man aber gut ich würde
sagen es zu gefallen hat und die
eventuell andere iphone spiele oder ipad
spieler kennt die spielen soll dann
schreibt man die kommentare zeigen